>> From the Library of
Congress, in Washington, DC.
>> Sy Damle: Good morning everyone.
Welcome to the first of two
round table hearings on the topic
of copyright law as it relates to
software-enabled consumer products.
I'm Sy Damle.
I'm Deputy General Counsel
of the copyright office,
and I'll let my colleagues
introduce themselves.
Catherine Rowland:
I'm Kitty Rowland.
I'm senior advisor to the register.
>> John Riley: I'm John
Riley, attorney advisor.
>> Michelle Choe: I'm
Michelle Choe, ringer fellow.
>> Sy Damle: So I'll
just do a quick intro,
and then we can start
with the first panel.
So in October 2015, the Senate
Judiciary Committee asked the
copyright office to study copyright
issues related to the spread
of software in what it
called everyday products.
And in its letter,
the committee observed
that digital technologies
have revolutionized our world
and that copyrighted software is
now essential to the operation
of our refrigerators, our
cars, our family equipment,
our wireless phones, and virtually
any other device you can think of.
While crediting our
intellectual property laws
for these developments,
the committee noted
that questions are being asked
about how consumers can
lawfully use products
that rely on software to function.
The committee directed us to
undertake a comprehensive review
of the role of copyright in this
area while acknowledging that many
of these issues may relate to
areas outside of copyright law.
So first of all, I'd like to thank
the committee for this assignment
and for its recognition of the
office's longstanding interest
in expertise in the intersection
of copyright law and technology.
Second, I'd like to thank all
of the groups and individuals
that submitted written comments in
response to our notice of inquiry.
We reviewed them all carefully,
and they were very helpful
in identifying the issues before us.
And third, I'd like to thank all
of you who agreed to participate
in this round table to help us take
a deeper dive into these issues.
So some of you are
veterans of our round table,
so you know how this works, but
for the others, if you want to jump
in on the conversation, just
turn your table tent upright,
and we'll call on you
hopefully in some fair order.
And just an explanation
of the microphones.
In order to speak, you have to
press the button, the silver button,
and the light will
turn red when it's on.
Only four people at once can have
their lights, the microphones on,
so after you're done talking,
if you could just please turn
your mic off, that would be great.
And just a disclaimer that
your remarks are being recorded
and will be transcribed made part
of the public record and available
on the copyright office website,
and the panel obviously
is being videotaped,
and the video will be
made available as well.
So we've got four panels
lined up today,
three before lunch
and one after lunch.
And there'll be an opportunity
for observer comments at the end,
and I hope we'll have a
productive conversation today.
Our first panel is about
a fairly general topic.
It's the proper role of copyright
in protecting software-enabled
consumer products,
and the goal of the panel is
to explore over-arching issues
like the need for copyright
protection in embedded software,
whether software in everyday
products can be distinguished
from other types of software, and
the need for interoperability.
But before I start off with a
question, we'd appreciate it if each
of you could introduce yourself
and explain your affiliation
for the record.
So we'll start with you.
>> Shaun J. Bockert: Hi, I'm
Shaun Bockert, of Blank Rome,
and I'm here representing
Doorman [phonetic] Products, Inc.,
a supplier of new and
remanufactured automotive parts.
>> Christian Troncoso: Hi,
I'm Christian Troncoso.
I'm here representing BSA,
The Software Alliance.
>> John Bergmayer:
I'm John Bergmayer,
and I'm here for Public Knowledge.
>> Ben Golant: Hi, Ben Golant,
representing the Entertainment
Software Association,
represents computer and
video game industry.
>> Jonathan Band: I'm Jonathan Band.
I'm here on behalf of the
Owner's Rights Initiative.
>> Keith Kupferschmid:
Keith Kupferschmid,
the CEO of the Copyright Alliance.
We represent 15,000
organizations and individuals
who copyright is very,
very important to.
>> Aaron Lowe: Aaron Lowe, I'm
with the Auto Care Association.
We represent manufacturers,
distributors, retailers,
and installers of automotive
parts independent
of the vehicle manufacturers.
>> Steve Tepp: Steve Tepp,
representing the Global
Intellectual Property Center
of the U.S. Chamber of Commerce.
>> Chris Mohr: Chris Mohr, Software
and Information Industry
Association.
>> Jonathan Zuck: Jonathan Zuck
from ACT, The App Association.
>> Sy Damle: Great.
Well thanks very much.
So to start things off,
the committee asked us
to examine the specific issue of
copyright issues related to software
in what they called
everyday products.
And we understand the
committee to have not asked us
for a more comprehensive review of
copyright and software generally.
So with that understanding, I
think that raises a key issue here,
which is whether there are problems
in the marketplace that are specific
to software-enabled
consumer devices and if
so whether those problems
can be solved
without affecting copyright
protection
for software more generally.
So, to sort of open up, if anyone
wants to comment on that issue,
just tip your table tent up.
Mr. Band?
>> Jonathan Band: So
I think it's easy
to distinguish software generally
from software that is embedded
in products, and I, you
know, it's should be possible
to craft special rules for the
software embedded in products
without necessarily
implicating software generally.
Where you're going to have
definitional issues is
like what does it mean to
be embedded or sort of,
you know software-enabled
product, I mean that becomes a bit
of a definitional issue because
sometimes you're talking about,
you might be talking about
firmware, or you might be, you know,
where really it is fixed, but you
also might be talking about programs
where you, you know, devices where
you have to download the programs
or the user has to
install the software
in some way to make it work.
So that becomes a bit
of a trickier issue.
And then the other issue that
you need to decide is to sort
of distinguish between,
you know, everyday products
or consumer products
and other products.
[Inaudible] that's helpful to
distinguish, and I think in,
you know, in 2016, where, you
know, there's really no difference
between business uses,
consumer uses, private uses,
and it's not very helpful to
try to make that distinction,
inevitably a very artificial one.
>> Sy Damle: And in terms of
problems that you see specifically
with respect to, I mean,
sort of the premises
of the question was whether there
are problems that are specific
to consumer devices or
whether the problems are really
about software at large.
>> Jonathan Band: Well, I
would say that they are,
there are a specific set
of issues that we know now.
Certainly, you know, and
we'll be getting into it more
in later panels, but the whole
first sale, there's the ability
to transfer products, you know, the
kinds of things that we've talked
about in our comments, and I know
some of the other people have talked
about it, but, you know,
the ability to sell devices,
repair devices, and
customize devices.
I mean those kinds of things
that are sort of unique
to when you have the software in the
device, there are things you want
to do with the device that are,
you don't really care
about the software.
I mean the software just
happens to be there.
>> Sy Damle: So I'm
not sure exactly,
I think it was you,
Mr. Troncoso, yeah.
>> Christian Troncoso: I'd like
to just pick up on both the points
that Jonathan raised, both in
regards to sort of the distinction
between consumer devices
and everyday devices,
and devices that are not every day.
And then on the embedded software
issue, I think that we agree
on the first point with I think
the vast majority of commenters
that sort of distinguishing a device
as an everyday device is not a
particularly helpful designation
because it's just a category that's
going to be constantly evolving.
Technology, you know, ten years
ago we would never have imagined,
I think, the phones in our pockets
now have the computing power
that sort of exceeds that
which NASA used to land people
on the moon in the '60's.
So, I don't think that's
a helpful classification.
And then on the embedded software
classification, we don't think
that that's particularly useful
either because, you know,
we've had embedded software for
decades, but I think the problems
that people are identifying that
gave rise to this study relate
to the newer products, right.
We're not talking about
calculators or microwaves.
We're talking about the newer
classification of products
that are sort of internet
connected at all times,
the sort of the examples that came
up a lot in folks comments relate
to things like nest [phonetic],
and the issue there is not sort
of the embedded software, it's
that the software has a server sort
of interaction, and that the
software is more of a service
than sort of just mere
embedded software.
So the issues that people are
concerned about and rightly
so relate to how, you know, people's
relationships with these devices
that involve a continuous sort
of interaction with servers.
So I think sort of trying to narrow
the scope of this inquiry merely
to embedded software, I don't think
is particularly helpful either.
>> Sy Damle: So can I ask about--
so, I mean there's the one area
where the law arguably
draws a distinction is
in the computer rental amendments
act where it says, you know,
a computer program, which
is embodied in a machine,
which cannot be copied, and if you
look at the legislative history,
and we had a follow-on study,
you know, what they were talking
about were, I think, some
of the examples that were
in the senate letter, which were
automobiles, like those kinds
of consumer devices, calculators
I think with a mentioned,
which you mentioned as well.
Is that a viable distinction that
we could use if were hypothetically
to try to draw a distinction for
embedded software as you point
that that distinction that's in
the law now really doesn't work
to solve the problems that
anyone has identified.
>> Christian Troncoso:
Well I think my point is
that you know I'm not really sure
what problem specifically it is
that we're trying to address.
And sort of merely, you
know, there's been a lot of,
sort of people have focused a lot on
the issue of licensing of software
and sort of, you know, a lot of
the software that is embedded
on our consumer devices now
is transferred by a mechanism
of a license as opposed to a sale.
That I think is probably a little
bit different than what happened,
you know, when microwaves first
came onto the market in the '70s.
So my point is that I think it's
very hard to address these issues
without disrupting the overall
market for software at large.
>> Sy Damle: A lot of people have
their tents up, and I'm not--
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Okay, Mr. Lowe.
Thanks.
>> Aaron Lowe: So representing
the automotive parts area,
we've had a long history
of experience in patent law
with reversed engineering
parts, remanufacturing parts,
but the issue of copyright has
arisen in a much greater amount
because of the fact that software is
on almost all automotive parts now
that are being built into the
parts by the vehicle manufacturer,
which we think current
copyright law, you know,
does provide the ability to do that,
but the need for clarification,
because there are a lot of issues
when you're remanufacturing parts,
where software needs to be used, we
need to, we look at software more
as an automotive part or
function rather than the actual,
you know, any creative thing.
So, like a windshield wiper might
have a software embedded into it.
It's taking the case
of a mechanical part
that would have been
on there before.
So we look at the whole issue
of software as being, you know,
very close to being
to an item that you,
mechanical you could
reverse engineer, copy,
and use again to put on, to
make a copy of that part.
And I think there's a lot
of concern in our industry
because we're no longer, you know,
the vehicle manufacturers seem
to view this in different light,
and I think that's created a lot of,
maybe misconceptions and
concerns in our industry,
and also has generated lawsuits in
our industry of our manufacturers.
So we really think our industry
needs a lot of clarification of some
of these issues because they
are creating problems for those
that reverse engineer and build
competitive parts and those
who do service on vehicles.
>> Sy Damle: So you mentioned
lawsuits, and you also mentioned it
in your written comments.
I mean, can you explain exactly
what those lawsuits involve,
whether they involve-- so I know
that there's the Al-Tel
[phonetic] litigation going on,
which really is not
directly about the software.
It's really about the, I think it's
the data compilation case basically.
So can you just sort of explain
what kind of litigation is going on?
>> Aaron Lowe: Well, you know, I
can, we have representatives here
that are involved in that.
I can let them answer that
question maybe more specifically,
but they involve the use of software
on an aftermarket part used on a car
and whether they had the ability
to, you know, because they needed
to use software to integrate with
that vehicle, you had to copy it
to do that, and I think that
specifically is more of the issue,
but we can let someone, you
know, another representative talk
about that more specifically.
But that's the concern of
being able to use software
to make sure it's interoperable
with a vehicle part,
and sometimes you have to copy
it to make sure it does that.
>> Sy Damle: And is it your view, I
mean, you mentioned at the beginning
that you thought the current
copyright doctrine could have
addressed those but that you
wanted clarification on that.
>> Aaron Lowe: I think there
needs to be more clarification
as how it relates to the
aftermarket and replacement parts,
reverse engineering, and also
servicing of vehicles too.
>> Catherine Rowland: Can I ask
if you have a recommendation
for this clarification?
>> Aaron Lowe: I think we had it
in our testimony that we submitted.
I think just clarification about
the use, and I think we'll get
into a lot of these issues
a little bit more closely
when we delve deeper
into it, but, you know,
the ability to copy the
software to use it as,
if it's a noncopyrightable,
it's just a functional issue,
interoperability, issues like that.
[ Background Noise ]
>> Sy Damle: Mr. Zuck.
>> Mr. Zuck.
>> Sy Damle: Okay, great.
>> Jonathan Zuck: Thanks.
And thanks for having me
here for this discussion.
I guess I just want to start
by saying that, you know,
as a former software developer
and now a representative
of software developers,
that software is the
thing in a lot of ways.
And I think it's easy to forget that
the huge strides and innovations
in computing have come predominantly
in software and that if you look
at something like a big
sensor, like a radio array,
and you look at Seti [phonetic], the
only reason we're going to be able
to filter the potential
for, you know,
extraterrestrial intelligence
is because of software.
You know, just imagine if you
had that functionality on C-Span,
it would be a lot easier to watch.
But so innovation in CAT scans
and a lot of machines come
through software, and software
is regularly updated regardless
of what your definition
is of embedded.
I mean it is a live and dynamic
part of the software and central
to the incredible advance
in software has been
copyright protection.
It has created incentives to invest,
etc., and if you change them,
you will change those
incentives, I think,
and so you will change
artificially the way
that people implement their
technology in order to find ways
to get protection for what
they're doing as opposed
to actually creating more innovation
in a space that's already
highly innovative.
I represent, you know, app makers,
and increasingly apps
are finding their way
into devices whether it's scales
or cars or refrigerators, etc.,
and that innovation, I think,
is going to be critical,
and I think that making a
distinction between everyday use,
I agree is a very specious one.
I mean, very critical
sensors are in, you know,
thing like Apple watches
and Microsoft band, etc.,
and that's going to be something
somebody uses every day,
and yet those are health related.
So I think there's a
real incentives problem,
and I think ultimately you're
going to start to see a problem
around liability too that,
you know, I've guaranteed
to protect somebody's
data in a particular way,
and my software is going to
be critical to doing that.
I'm making assertions about the
accuracy of a particular device,
and software is going to be critical
to making those assertions
real or not.
Compatibility and fragmentation
of underlying technology.
I mean I'm an avid
photographer, and the firmware
of my camera is constantly
being updated for compatibility
with different lenses and things
like that, and yet there are efforts
to hack camera firmware, to
add functionality in parallel,
and if you do those things, you
sort of do them at your own risk
because you're now out of the branch
of the enhancements that are coming
from the manufacturer
for the different hardware
that you wanted to use.
And so then it raises questions
about, you know, who do you call
when your camera bricks up
because you've fiddled with it.
And I think that, I think all of
that is important to keep in mind
as context for the discussion.
Getting to specifics, I fail to see
that there's been any real problem
that's been identified here that's
specific to software
embedded in devices.
It's all theoretical.
It doesn't seem to be real,
and I think that the copyright
system has provided a set of kind
of release valves already.
There's exceptions built into
things like the DMCA, etc.,
that are specifically designed
for interoperability and study,
security, etc., that have been
used effectively and to the extent
to which there have been court
cases around software being used
and copyright being used
sort of illegitimately.
They've sort of fallen
the way I think
that people believe
they should have.
So it seems to me that it's
a system that's working
and that there's no sign
of a systemic problem.
Instead, there's a
system that works,
and we ought to be very
cautious about changing it.
>> Sy Damle: Thank you, Mr. Zuck.
I think we'll go down this
line and then come back.
How about that?
So, Mr. Golant.
>> Ben Golant: Thank you, and
it's a pleasure being back here
at the copyright office and
being part of this conversation.
I want to first echo what
Christian and Jonathan have said.
I agree with their assessments
of the current environment,
and I think the broad point I want
to make is at first do not harm
to the copyright protection system
for software under
the copyright act.
That should be the ultimate
goal of this particular study.
And in terms of how you
differentiate, I think in terms
of what ESA members care
about, whether it be console,
manufacturers, or hand-held
devices or even the new VR,
virtual reality units, every
piece of software has a function,
and you can't differentiate one
kind of software versus another
because they all interoperate,
they all link together,
they all make that device that makes
all our consumers very, very happy.
So there can't be any line drawing
because that would be
regulatory chaos to say this kind
of software is not
protected or this kind
of software should be
treated differently.
So the bottom line is whatever
our members care about,
and that is having an integrated
unit that makes things go
and makes the games go, that's
how we should like to maintain it,
just keep the protections under the
act for software the way they are.
>> Sy Damle: And what's your
view of the line that's drawn
in the computer rental
amendments act.
Is that, I mean obviously that's
about a very specific issue, but,
you know, there's both an exception
for what they say computer
program embodied in the machine
that can't be copied, and then
there's a separate one actually
for video games that are also
embodied and can't be copied, so--
>> Ben Golant: Right.
And I know exactly what you're
talking about, but I can talk
about that a little bit later,
but right now I'll keep
the statements I just made.
>> Sy Damle: Okay.
Mr. Bergmayer?
>> John Bergmayer: Yeah, thank you.
I think underlying the use
of the phrase everyday products
is this notion that, you know,
consumer products are different
than say large scale commercial,
industrial, agricultural users
and that consumers have
particular expectations and rights
and protections that might not
apply to a factory buying a bunch
of software-controlled CNC
machinery or something.
And I think that's probably
totally true; however,
I don't think that
copyright law is the right way
to draw those distinctions
between classes of users.
You already have contract law,
already makes distinctions
between sophisticated
users and commercial users.
I'm not an expert in this
commercial law stuff,
but I'm pretty sure the
UCC or something makes note
of those different classes,
and particularly, you know,
from a consumer group perspective,
something that concerns me is
the notion of using licenses
to disclaim liability for
defects and products just
because they're software and you can
condition a software license on it
where you couldn't with other
ordinary consumer products.
And I think, you know, consumer law
already deals with things like that.
You know, a lot of states
have rules which say
that no matter how many times a
manufacturer of a product tries
to disclaim a warranty,
it's ineffective.
They have certain liabilities
that are defined by law,
and there's no getting around them.
Yet those protections
typically wouldn't apply
to a sophisticated commercial
buyer of industrial machinery,
and I think that's a totally
appropriate distinction to draw,
and it's not really necessary for
a copyright law to even be a part
of that discussion of how
do you protect consumers
versus how do you not
protect consumers,
and my concern is the potential
use of copyright law to try to,
you know, whittle away
some of those rights
where software vendors
typically disclaim all liability
for any use whatsoever and they
say that their product is not fit
for any purpose and
things like that,
which maybe they might make
sense in a pure software context,
although I'm skeptical, but in a
typical consumer product standpoint
where you have software that
is controlling power tools
or a rice cooker, you know, I'm
very skeptical of things like that.
But I don't think that
it is copyright law
that should really be part
of the discussion in terms
of those sorts of consumer
protection.
>> Sy Damle: And is it your
view that to the extent
that there are licenses that
do that that the state laws
that you mentioned would
apply to those types of,
to those types of licenses.
>> John Bergmayer: I think
it is unknown basically.
I think questions like that would
have to be litigated to the question
of whether a disclaimer
in a software license would
have greater legal effect
than a typical warranty disclaimer,
which in some states might
not have any legal effect.
I simply don't know, and I think
that we can either start thinking
about these issues now or we can
just wait for there to be decades
of litigation in a piecemeal fashion
that might vary state by state,
and I think that's the direction
we're heading towards right now.
>> Sy Damle: And is it your sense
that Congress needs to do something
to fix this, or is this something
that, like what is it, what--
>> John Bergmayer: Well, in
our comments, our position is
that if you simply reject certain
interpretations of copyright law
that I think are mistaken that have
been adopted by some circuit courts,
it's not necessary; however,
certainly I would welcome
Congressional clarification of any
of the policy points that
we've identified if it was
at all feasible, but, you know, I
think right now we're really not
at the stage of proposing
specific legislation so much
as identifying the fault lines.
>> Sy Damle: Okay, thanks.
And we can delve into some
of the licensing issues you
mentioned in the next panel.
>> John Bergmayer: Sure.
>> Mr. Bockert:
>> Sy Damle: Mr. Bockert, yeah.
>> Shaun J. Bockert: So, I guess
to start, I'm sort of confused
by this resistance to drawing
lines, because it seems like we do
that all the time in the law,
and we do it in copyright law,
and we do it in patent law, and
we do it in trademark law, and,
you know, we're relatively
comfortable with that.
And I guess maybe one thing
that's coming up, and I, you know,
I don't think we dispute this, is
that maybe it's not the, you know,
the embedded line that is
where we draw the distinction,
and maybe it's not the
everyday products line
where we draw the distinction.
But I would pause at that software
that serves a primarily
functional role in a product ought
to be treated differently, and the,
you know, the reasoning there is,
you know, when you think about
it in the context of patent,
we have these things that
serve functional roles
in their specific [inaudible],
like the [inaudible] repair,
and all sorts of, you know,
exemptions from the rights owner's
exclusive rights, and we think that,
you know, several of
those [inaudible]
and exemptions should also apply
in the context of copyright.
>> Sy Damle: So when you say a
primarily functional role, I mean,
all software at some
level is functional.
It's telling, it's telling, you
know, transistors to go to one
or zero, and so I'm wondering,
I just want to dig into
that a little more.
Like do you mean a
mechanical role or--
>> Shaun J. Bockert: Sure,
it's a good question.
Yeah, it's a perfect question.
So, yes, I think, so Aaron gave the
example of windshield wipers, right?
So at one time you might
have had a mechanism
that decided how frequently a
windshield wiper should swish,
right?
I'm sure there's a technical term
for swishing, but I don't know it.
And, you know, and
that would be a device
that would be covered
by patent, right?
And auto part makers could come in,
and they could figure out, you know,
what's going on there,
and they could figure
out what their rights were in order
to replace it under patent law.
But now that mechanical unit
has been replaced entirely
with software, and so now we've
sort of lost this aftermarket,
and ultimately it's
consumers who are struggling.
And that's not to say
that, you know, we don't--
I think that to sort of
respond to some of the--
that's not to say that we
don't respect, you know,
copyright ownership, and you know
the strong incentives that there are
in coding and creating
software, but it's to say
that we also have competing, you
know, incentives and motivations
and that there are ancillary markets
that we should also
consider when making the law.
>> Sy Damle: And is it your
sense, I mean there's a lot of,
there's sort of established
case law about interoperability,
and I know we're going to
talk about the fair use,
we have a fair use panel coming up
third, I think, but just in general,
is your sense that the current
case law about allowing things
like reverse engineering
and intermediate copies
for reverse engineering and
enabling interoperability,
do you think that case
law is sort of sufficient
to give your clients
comfort, or is there more
that needs to be done there?
>> Shaun J. Bockert: No,
I think we need more,
and I don't think it's
limited to interoperability.
I think it would be a
replacement as well.
>> Sy Damle: Okay, thank you.
Mr. Kupferschmid.
>> Keith Kupferschmid: Thank you.
So, I actually last week
was in San Francisco
for the five twelve section round
tables, and it's interesting
if you look at the record and the
description of all the problems
that people are having with the
DMCA notice and takedown process,
and you compare that to the record
here, it's just night and day.
I mean, there is very little
if any evidence of a problem.
If you look through the examples
and the written testimony,
you'll see a lot of mays
and coulds and mights,
but you don't really
see the pure facts.
And to the extent there are
pure, you know, facts, examples,
I think many of them
don't have anything to do
with the copyright law itself
and have to do with other things.
And I think there are other sessions
where we'll delve into that more,
although I'm happy to
do that now as well.
So in terms of this line drawing
for embedded software,
that's one problem.
And everyday consumer products,
that's another problem.
I think it's interesting that the
one person here that suggested
that no we should not have a problem
with any line drawing
then draws a line
that encompasses every single
piece of software out there
by calling it just, you
know, that any software
that serves a functional
role, which is as you point
out the definition of
sort of all software.
So this line drawing frankly is
very difficult if not impossible
in this particular
situation both in terms
of what embedded software
means and what it means
to be an everyday consumer product,
and not only is it difficult,
but tissue not helpful.
We already hear complaints
from the public and users
that copyright law is too complex,
and now we're hearing suggestions
that not only should we, well should
we make the copyright law more
complex by creating a sort of a
subcategory of software and treat
that differently than
other types of software.
And then we don't treat it
differently in all types
of situations, just when it's
in everyday consumer
products, whatever that means.
So this is just a hornets' nest of
trying to draw that dividing line,
which I think is a real problem.
In terms of you've been asking
this question to others,
so I'm going to preempt you and
just try to answer this myself,
you mentioned the rental
right limitation
and whether that's
a viable distinction
in this particular
instance, but you also point
out that Congress considered
that issue
when it codified this
rental right limitation.
It knew about the issue and decided
to limit it to the rental right,
not apply it across the board.
So I think that's significant that
Congress did consider this issue
and decided to apply it
in a particular fashion
and in a particular manner.
And then just lastly with regard to
licensing issues, I'll pass on those
because also in session I think
it's two we'll take those up,
so there were a host of
issues that are raised
in that context, but
I'll wait on that.
>> Sy Damle: Mr. Tepp.
>> Steve Tepp: Thanks very much.
So one of the prior commenters
made the statement that with regard
to certain products the software
just happens to be there,
and I don't think I could
disagree any more fundamentally
with that statement.
Software is not just decoration.
Software makes the
products more efficient.
They make it more safer.
This is why software has
accounted for 15 percent
of all U.S. labor productivity
gains from 2004 to 2012.
And I think what this points
to is really the fundamental
policy question
that underlies the
entire conversation today,
which is on the one hand we have
a vibrant software industry.
The United States unquestionably
leads the world in this field.
Three point two percent
of our entire GDP is
from software industry.
Exports of software and related
services have grown by nine
to ten percent every
year since 2006.
We have something in our system,
and I think it's beyond
any serious question
that copyright law is an
important part of that system
that has generated a
vibrant, productive industry
that has helped the
entire country innovate
and move forward into
the modern era.
So that's the one hand.
On the other hand, as several of
my co-panelists have pointed out,
the concerns that are being
raised are often hypothetical.
There are some anecdotes.
Very little of it is
traceable actually
to copyright law as the problem.
So thus put I think
it's fairly clear
that there's a very high threshold
for demonstrating any need for,
as we'll get to later in the
day, a fairly drastic remedy
of preempting contract
terms, and I don't think
that threshold has been met.
And I'll just, coming back to
the 117 rental issue that's come
up a few times, I'll just add
to what Keith said a moment ago
with which I agree, that that
amendment was actually designed
to protect copyright and software,
the rental of software
was leading to piracy.
People would rent the back then
floppy disk, take it home, copy it,
and then return the
object of the rental.
To the extent that at the time
that amendment was passed,
the ability to engage in that type
of piracy and other types of objects
where you didn't have the
floppy disk at your disposal,
I think is a significant part of
why Congress made that distinction.
It was not a distinction designed to
denigrate the protection of software
in other areas but to enhance
its protection in areas
where it was the most
vulnerable to piracy.
It's an open question as to going
forward whether piracy is becoming
easier across the board, but I
think it's important to remember
that origin of that provision.
>> Sy Damle: Well you raised piracy,
I mean I guess one question is,
are there concerns about
piracy in embedded software
and in circumstances sort
of where that exception
to the consumer rental, the computer
rental amendments act applies,
where you have a nest thermostat
which has software in it.
Ordinarily it would be pretty
hard to copy the software off
of that device, but you suggested
maybe that's not the case anymore,
so I don't know if you
want to discuss that?
>> Steve Tepp: Well, I think we
can all foresee that as it's easier
and easier to have in ordinary
consumers' hands the ability
to access software that is embedded
in a thermostat, as you posit.
Then piracy does I think
become a greater concern.
>> Sy Damle: But piracy, I
mean what would be the purpose
of such piracy if you
don't, I mean--
>> Steve Tepp: Well, if the software
is the distinguishing characteristic
of a product that gives it
a competitive advantage,
and I wanted to compete in that
marketplace, then I would benefit
from pirating that software into a
competing product, just one example.
>> Sy Damle: So it's
more competitors rather
than sort of mass market piracy?
>> Steve Tepp: You know, there's
so much innovation in this space,
I don't pretend to have
the imagination necessary
to envision every possible scenario.
The fundamental case I'm making is
that the laws we have now have
generated incredibly successful
industry that has Congress
has duly considered
where exceptions are necessary and
appropriate and has codified those
into the statute and that
there is not evidence,
not anywhere near enough evidence
to suggest a drastic
remedy that's proposed.
You asked a question about
piracy going forward.
I was pointing out that was
Congress' motivation in the past
in the section 117 amendment.
To the extent you're
asking me going forward,
are there potentially piracy
concerns, I don't want to rule them
out because I don't know.
I can imagine the scenario
where there could be.
>> Sy Damle: Okay, thank you.
Mr. Mohr? And then we'll go
over to I think Mr. Bergmayer,
then Mr. Band, and then
back to you, Mr. Zuck.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Oh, sorry.
And then we'll end up with you.
Okay.
>> Chris Mohr: Thank you.
A few, and I'll try to brief
and not overly redundant.
The first-- I do think it's from
our perspective important to look
at this not from a framework of
problems but frankly a framework
of overwhelming success, and that
is namely that the application
of copyright to software has
been enormously successful
in spurring innovation, and we've
heard numbers and statistics
about that, and we
had some, you know,
we put some in our filing as well.
Not only has it been true
for software generally,
but you're also seeing an enormous
amount of investment in the internet
of thing in terms of venture
capital, and we've cited some
of that stuff in our
footnotes as well.
And so I guess when we hear
about these things we say,
okay, well what's the problem.
And frankly for us there isn't one,
and there isn't one for
a couple of reasons.
The first is that the
copyright law has enabled us
to have both predictable and
flexible business models.
That licensing model
has worked very well.
It's worked very well not only
for our member software companies,
but we also see it potentially
working well in the internet
of things as software in that space
becomes more and more like a service
and as consumers develop
ongoing relationships
and in some cases very
specific relationships
with their software providers for a
variety of different kinds of data.
It will make sense to maintain
the integrity of those products
that the use of them be
subject to particular terms.
And there's no reason that people,
if they don't want to be subject
to those terms or if they don't
want to offer material subject
to those terms create a
different business model.
There is nothing preventing
them from doing that.
So we don't see any
useful distinction
or manageable distinction that
can be drawn between software
in consumer products in
any other type of software.
For us, that is a false premise.
The second thing, I know it's more
in the licensing area that I want
to say, but I was confused
by something that one
of our colleagues mentioned
before about the difference
between the application
of commercial law
to particular transactions
and when things go wrong,
and I don't think there
is a big difference
between licensing and
product liability.
Product liability is a tort,
and it's a tort under state law.
So if something causes a,
for example, a car to crash,
the liability will sound in tort.
It is not going to be governed by
the terms of a license agreement
because that's, I mean that comes
out of the Bloomfield Motors case
from the first year of law school.
I think that's a very
different type of analysis.
So trying to mix those
kinds of horribles together.
I mean, look, years ago when we were
dealing with the aftermath of ProCD
and the world was going
to collapse around us,
we heard very similar claims about
this, and it simply didn't happen.
But this is one of the,
this was one of the areas
that was mentioned back then,
and I think the point is
equally applicable today,
is that where there would be
product liability law that applied
in the absence of privity,
there's nothing, there isn't much
that a software license
can do to prevent that.
>> Sy Damle: Okay, thank you.
Mr. Bergmayer, I think
you were next.
>> John Bergmayer: Sure, so
something that just relates
to the functionality
discussion, a little bit earlier,
and I'll use the windshield
wiper example that keeps coming
up because I just recently replaced
the windshield wiper in my car.
It was a very complicated,
mechanical contrivance.
It was really difficult to get
right, and I can imagine, yeah,
it's replaced with a much simpler
part, that is the micro controller
with some software, you know,
connected to some motors,
and I think the question is I bought
an aftermarket windshield wiper
armature replacement thing.
Could I buy a replacement
micro controller
with different software
written by someone else,
and I think when you have software
that is of such a simple character,
you end up with almost
merger doctrine issues
where if someone else
re-implemented software
that did the exact same thing
in terms of controlling the arms
in a particular way, it very well
might be the case that looking
at the original software
and someone's independently
created software
that does the same functions
in terms of controlling motors,
you might see substantial
similarity,
yet at a certain point
you have to have an idea,
expression dichotomy issue because
you can't copyright the only
or the most efficient
way to accomplish a task.
You know, similarly if I in a
new programming language, say go,
I'm the first person to come
up with the most efficient way
to implement a particular
sorting algorithm.
It might be very creative of me,
but that's not subject to copyright
because that is an idea
expression dichotomy question.
So I think there are existing
copyright law doctrines
that have been around for a
really long time that at least
when it comes to the very simple
software that is just sort
of replacing a mechanical
part could ready apply
to at least prevent the use
of copyright to, you know,
to limit competition by
people making other, you know,
competing products, and I think
that is, it's just something
that people need to keep in mind
when considering these things.
>> Sy Damle: Okay, thank you.
Mr. Band.
>> Jonathan Band: So some
folks on the other side
of the room have said repeatedly
that there is no evidence.
Now simply saying that there is
no evidence doesn't make all the
evidence that's already been
submitted in the record vanish.
You know, you have to actually
look what's in the record,
and so we've had Mr. Lowe
submit, you know, you know,
comments on behalf of thousands
of auto repair folks who deal
with this problem of replacement
parts and exactly the kinds
of things we're talking about
here, and the competition
and the aftermarket and
the diagnostic software,
all of these related issues, they
deal with that problem every day.
I represent, within the Owner's
Rights Initiative are two trade
associations representing
computer resellers
and independent repair providers,
and they deal with this
issue every single day.
The Cisco frequently asked questions
specifically talks about resell
and restrictions that they
place on resale of their servers
because of the software and
they cite Verner v. AutoDesk.
It's in their frequency
asked questions.
It's not an occasionally
asked question.
It's a frequently asked question,
which indicates that people who want
to buy these materials
frequently ask that question.
HP has the same thing in their
frequently asked questions.
So this is, and the
issue of independent,
the issue of competition in the
aftermarket has been an issue,
an ongoing issue, competitively
in the computer industry
from the beginning and
the independent software,
independent maintenance and repair.
It's been a big issue from
the beginning, and, you know,
117 was amended precisely
to deal with that.
I mean it's a constant struggle.
Now in the competitive
struggle in Congress,
typically the original equipment
manufacturers have a lot more
lobbying power than the independent
repair folks, but that doesn't mean
that the outcome that they are
pushing for and have pushed
for is necessarily
from a [inaudible] perspective
of the optimal outcome.
I mean the point is is that
again, this is an issue.
Right now we see it very much in
the, you know, the computer area
and in the automotive area, and it's
important for you all to focusing
on this now because
very soon it's going
to be applying everywhere else.
>> Sy Damle: So if I can
just defend Congress,
since I have representatives from
Congress sitting in the audience.
I mean they did, just to push back
on that point, they did, you know,
after MAI, they did issue an
amendment to section 117 to address
that specifically out of concern
for the independent repair to sort
of facilitate independent repair,
to deal with that particular issue,
and so I think there is evidence
that there's that kind of,
that sort of problem
happening today.
I think, I imagine we would be
and Congress would be
willing to examine that.
So that takes me to the next point,
which is, I think it's one thing
to say that there are issues,
and there are obviously lots
of difficult issues in copyright law
and determining whether
something is [inaudible]
or not is a difficult issue,
and so I'm just wondering whether
you have sort of specific examples
of either, you know, threats of
litigation or litigation or sort
of areas where it's like
clear that that's something
that an independent repair person
or someone who's making
an aftermarket part wants
to do is being prevented from doing
because of current copyright law.
>> Jonathan Band: Well, my, you
know, the folks within ORI report
that they are, you know,
constantly being pushed
around by the large
computer manufacturers,
that more importantly their
customers are being told not
to get the services and not to buy,
you know, used and replacement parts
and so forth from my people.
And that's what inspired our group
to work with Congressman [inaudible]
in support of YODA [phonetic].
I mean, that's, that was a very
specific bill that was responding
to a specific problem
that our members say
that they encounter all the time.
I don't think there's been a
complaint filed that I'm aware of,
but it is a constant issue.
>> Sy Damle: And do you have, I
mean, so I looked at the licenses
that you cited and sort of
looked up for example, NetApp,
and NetApp is an enterprise
data storage company.
Cisco, as far as I could
tell, applies those sorts
of restrictive license terms on
its enterprise level devices.
And I couldn't, what I couldn't find
from your submission was an example
of sort of a consumer level device,
or even a small business
level device
that had these sorts of,
these sorts of issues.
And I assume that you
would concede in sort
of business-to-business context,
there's much more sort of a balance
of bargaining power,
and so I think what one
of our concerns is again
to draw the distinction.
I think it's appropriate and the
law does, as Mr. Bergmayer said,
draw a distinction between
enforcing contracts between sort of,
between two businesses and
between a business and a consumer
where it's a click through or
contract [inaudible] if you will.
Right, so I think that, so I'm just
curious whether you have examples
of sort of consumer level devices
that have that type of problem.
>> Jonathan Band: Well even
when it says enterprise level,
I mean there are different
kinds of enterprises.
You might have an enterprise
of 20 people or 30 people,
and so they might have a server
for that level of enterprise,
but it's still, we're not
talking about, you know,
a 100,000-person company dealing
with another 100,000-person company.
And again, we see this, you
know, this is the history
of the computer industry that you
have very unequal bargaining power.
And you really can't bargain with
Cisco or HP or NetApp if you're a,
you know, even a, you know, a
small to medium sized business.
And some of the products that the
ORI members deal with are also like,
it could be equipment like
this, like these speakers,
these microphones or telephones,
and so you might have a small office
where you might have ten telephones
or five telephones, and again,
you have very little, very
unequal bargaining strength
between the small business and
the equipment manufacturer.
[ Background Noise ]
>> Mr. Bockert.
>> Sy Damle: Sorry.
>> Shaun J. Bockert: So,
my client Doorman Products,
is facing a very real
lawsuit for, you know,
alleging copyright
infringement, and they're,
you know, having to defend that.
So this isn't sort of theoretical
and it's not hypothetical.
It's very real, and, you know, I
can't go into all of the details
of the case and sort of
foreshadowing defenses,
but the idea is I think this--
>> Sy Damle: I'm sorry,
has a complaint been filed?
>> Shaun J. Bockert: Yes,
a complaint has been filed.
>> Sy Damle: Okay.
I think we would be interested in
seeing, if you have the docket site,
we'd be interested in seeing that.
>> Shaun J. Bockert:
I can send that.
>> Sy Damle: Yeah, that'd be great.
>> Shaun J. Bockert: Sure.
So, and, you know, we obviously
think we have very clear defenses
and we think that existing copyright
law allows us to do what it is
that we've been doing, but we
think that this could be clearer,
specifically focusing on,
you know, section 117,
which everyone is talking about,
and I think when you open that up,
I have the, you know, the
utmost respect for the drafters
in Congress, but it's very
difficult to read section 117C
to an auto mechanic and have
them understand it in a clear way
and have them understand how
that applies to their business.
And so when you have those
difficulties, you, you know,
it does create chilling
effects and innovation.
And, you know, it's not only
Doorman who experiences this.
I get phone calls from
several clients who are calling
and saying hey, I have
this idea, can I do this?
And I have to say, well, you
know, here are the limitations
and here are the things that you
have to consider under copyright.
And, you know, a lot of them
walk away and don't, you know,
end up creating whatever business
it is that they had in mind.
And I think keeping
all of this in mind,
a lot of people are
talking about, you know,
the success of the
software industry.
I don't think anyone would
dispute that, but I do think
that there is some, you know,
assumption there that the success
of the software industry is
based entirely on, you know,
the strength of its
protections under copyright.
When historically a lot of the
software protections were based
under patent law, and patent law
has very clear exceptions for things
that you're allowed to do,
like the doctrine of repair.
And I think what we're positing is
some of those exceptions should be,
should more clearly apply in
the context of copyright law.
>> Sy Damle: Okay.
We're running short on time, so I'm
just going to run down this side,
and then we'll wrap up this panel.
Mr. Kupferschmid.
>> Keith Kupferschmid: So, I'll be
brief, I mean just to throw it back
in Jonathan's lap here I suppose
a little bit is that, you know,
he said just because you say the
problems don't exist doesn't mean
they don't exist.
Well the opposite, just because
you say there are problems,
doesn't mean there are problems.
And especially--
>> I'll remember that the next
time you guys submit that you need
to change the copyright act.
>> Keith Kupferschmid:
Okay, and I'll watch
for your tent to go
up next time too.
But anyway, so the problems that,
or the issues that
have been raised here,
the concerns that have been raised
here, a lot of them have very little
if anything to do with the
copyright with deference
to Mr. Beckert is it, Bockert.
I don't recall reading the case,
and I would also love to take a look
at the case, but it seems like
it has not been adjudicated yet.
So the court's may
come to the, you know,
obviously to the right
decision at the end of the day.
It is worth mentioning that
there are at least one,
probably many different voluntary
agreements having to do sort
of a right of repair at
least in automotive industry,
so it is worth mentioning that there
are groups that can come together
and address these issues too
outside of Congress or other places.
>> Sy Damle: Okay, thank you.
I'm not sure, Mr. Lowe, were you--
yeah, okay, Mr. Lowe,
and then Mr. Tepp.
>> Aaron Lowe: No, I wanted
to clarify, first of all,
the case is real, and we're
familiar with the case
that Mr. Bockert brought up, but
every day when companies are looking
at parts now they're looking at
software-enabled parts, most,
you know every day they have
to make a decision whether
to reverse engineer or
whether they can, you know,
innovate with the development
of that part,
and every day that decision
is affected by copyright law
so that there are very real
effects that are going on because
of this field and the need to
clarify the right to repair
in this software copyright area
because, you know, whether,
you know, we all say
software copyright is fine
and there are no problems,
well, this is, you know,
this is an area in automotive.
When you purchased a car, you
own that car and you are able
to modify it to do work
on that car, to repair it,
and that's been a longstanding
standard, but now with the software,
you know, software now implemented
on almost every part and component
on a car, that's now becoming more
difficult and more questionable,
and so what we're looking for is
more clarification in that area
to make sure that, you know,
when you do want to work
on a part you know that
there is a certain standard
that we've gotten used to in
the patent area is also applied
in the copyright area.
>> Sy Damle: Mr. Tepp.
>> Steve Tepp: Thank you.
So, oops, you know, the copyright
law already has clear jurisprudence
and codification by Congress of
reverse engineering for purposes
of interoperability, so,
and the Chamber is certainly not
here to take issue with that.
And the copyright office has
famously issued some 1201 rulings
that are in furtherance
of that goal.
So I think that ought not be lost
in question of replacement parts.
In terms of overall evidentiary
issues, again, you know,
even the cases that have been
brought up, you've, the panel,
this morning has distinguished
from copyright law respectfully a
frequently asked question is perhaps
not a scientific designation
of how often an issue may arise
to the extent that the concern
is oh my gosh, we have to think
about copyright law
when we do our business.
Well, yes, people have
legal property rights
that ought not be infringed
particularly
when there are means available under
the statute to engage in repair,
to engage in reverse engineering,
and none of this justifies,
as we'll get to later in
the discussion I suppose,
this notion of wholesale
preemption of contract terms,
which is an anathema to
the free market system
that copyright is designed
to work within.
And just coming back finally to the
piracy question we asked earlier,
the one point that occurred
to me I should have made is
that there is a clear and present
issue with piracy particularly
in the area where the device that's
run by software is the device
that helps perform and display
other forms of copyrighted works,
whether they be music,
movies, what not.
Absolutely in that context you
have the capacity for piracy
of either the software
and/or the works
that the device is
designed to perform.
>> Sy Damle: Mr. Zuck.
>> Jonathan Zuck: Thanks.
I'm not a lawyer and so
probably the least interested
in reading the complaint,
but as a software developer,
what I've seen historically
is there's always been a kind
of tension between intellectual
property and commoditization.
And that tension has been
interesting in a lot ways
that the argument is made
that eventual commoditization
actually leads
to innovation at some level.
But now the thing you were
protecting you don't have anymore,
and you now have to
re-innovate, etc.,
but there's also a historical
precedent that's sort
of like commoditization too soon can
undermine investment in innovation.
But I think the key thing here,
and this will come up over
and over again, is that we
should never confuse the two.
Commoditization is not innovation,
and very often innovation
is happening here.
Commoditization is happening
elsewhere, and so to look at that
as commoditization is an
innate good or as specifically
as innovation I think is a
frightening characteristic for it
because it's that innovation
that I think that we need
to make sure we're protecting and
the copyright was put in place
to protect and be very
cautious of things that sort
of institutionalize commoditization
too early in a product cycle.
>> Sy Damle: Okay.
Thank you.
Mr. Troncoso, do want
to have the last word?
>> Christian Troncoso: Thank you.
I think one of the
important questions
that Chairman Grassley [phonetic]
and Senator Leighey [phonetic] asked
in their letter that prompted this
study, is for you guys to look
into what provisions of the
copyright act sort of apply
and how they apply now in this era
where there's ubiquitous software
in our consumer devices, and one
of the things we've heard
repeatedly here on this panel is
that there seems to be
some misunderstanding
at least among some folks
about how existing safeguards
in the copyright act might
actually be there and might be able
to resolve some of
the problems and some
of the tensions that
we're experiencing.
So I think it would be helpful
for you guys in this study to talk
about that, talk about how
I know that 1201 is sort
of a four-letter word in this panel.
We're not supposed to talk about it,
but how the triennial rule making
is there to sort of provide sort
of a release on the tensions
that might build on sort of right
to repair like issues and
also how fair use cases
like Connectix [phonetic]
and Sega v. Accolade apply
to permit reverse engineering
for purposes of interoperability.
>> Sy Damle: So do you think it's
appropriate for the public to look
at our 1201 rule makings as guidance
with respect to questions about 117,
fair use, that sort of thing?
>> Christian Troncoso: I'm not sure,
I'm not sure if I would
prepared to go there, but--
>> Sy Damle: Okay.
Just curious.
All right, well that
wraps up our first panel.
Thanks very much.
What we'll do is we'll take a,
if we can take a 10-minute break
that would get us right back on
schedule, so we'll be back here
at 10:15 for session two.
Thanks.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.